bom gente fui convidado então para falar
sobre o futuro do trabalho
então não tem como escapar nesses 18
minutos de falar pelo menos sobre dois
assuntos trabalho e novos comportamentos
novos comportamentos atrelados bastante
o que eles têm estudado de
comportamentos que vem muito com uma
nova geração que vem hoje com a turma
que está se formando entrar no mercado
de trabalho e para falar sobre isso para
falar sobre futuro optei hoje
particularmente a falar sobre esse
futuro trazendo algumas questões
fundamentais sobre o presente sobre o
que eu tenho aprendido nesses últimos
anos uma série com centenas algum
centenas de jovens muito inspiradores
ah e pra falar exatamente sobre isso
eu tentei trazer quatro palavras de
certa forma os dois verbos você o verbo
fazer o verbo persistir e provocar aqui
um pensamento sobre dois conceitos é um
conceito que é o de novos ideais sobre o
trabalho a em detrimento de um
pensamento que seria novas idealizações
sobre o trabalho
eu quero nos provocar aqui a pensar
exatamente sobre essas duas perspectivas
então enfim eu sou andrés eu sou um dos
fundadores a esse outra empresa chamada
next hw que uma empresa especializada
fundamentalmente estudar comportamentos
novos comportamentos na sociedade e como
eles estão impactando nas relações de
trabalho e trazendo novos desafios das
grandes organizações desafios na área
por exemplo de atração de talentos
recrutamento engajamento vínculo e
cultura organizacional e seu espectro
que de alguma forma vem trabalhando nos
últimos anos
anexo ela ela nasceu de uma outra
empresa do nosso grupo que chama box
1824 uma empresa que há mais de dez anos
de estudo o comportamento jovem propõe
uma série de soluções para grandes
organizações também
que a mudou para particularmente nos fez
criar a anexo hw basicamente sem olhar
felizmente os cinco anos pra cá essas
organizações que são os nossos clientes
começaram a trazer questões mais
voltadas ao jovem dentro das próprias
organizações
estou exatamente como essas que comentei
como atrair talentos como engaja como
repensar a cultura movimentar nossas
empresas para lugares mais
contemporâneos e é dentro desse ambiente
então o que a gente vem trabalhando
tá bom esse é o contexto e é sobre isso
então eu quero usar aqui os meus quinze
minutos para trocar idéias aqui com
vocês a um dos pilares fundamentais
anexo
dentro dessas perspectivas é um pilar de
recrutamento tem hoje um time de jovens
que estão inseridos nas principais
faculdades do país não seria dos
principais eventos do país exatamente
identificando quem são jovens de impacto
jovens que são reconhecidos pelo
ambiente por deixarem seus legados por
deixarem suas marcas por onde passa
e essa essa experiência com centenas de
jovens assim tem sido muito rica porque
acho que nos coloca numa posição muito
interessante do da nossa cadeia de vida
nos permite olhar para trás
entendeu que o sistema de educação está
nos deixando de certa forma como
qualidade de ensino como qualidade de
seres humanos e de profissionais nos
permite olhar para dentro das
organizações entendeu os inúmeros
desafios que elas passem que ela se
propõe a passar para também evoluírem e
obviamente está contato com os jovens
incríveis entendendo muito das suas
vocações das suas potencialidades e
também das suas dores e hoje eu diria
que é o meu recado principal seria
primordialmente pra para os jovens
esses jovens estão entrando na faculdade
está entrando no mercado de trabalho e
especificamente eu quero inclusive
começar a falar sobre um tema que
geralmente também não fala nesse tipo de
evento
acho fundamental a gente também poder
falar
por vou começar falando um pouco por
algumas das dores dessa moçada e pra
falar isso então eu quero começar a
contando também o contexto que eu
entendo hoje no mercado de trabalho
é inegável que um poucos anos pra cá se
criou todo um novo discurso e todo um
novo ideal sobre o trabalho
questões como é como as que estão nessa
lista que vão bem além disso então
questões do tipo
a gente tem que amar o que a gente faz
encontrar o nosso propósito work life
delas ganhando dinheiro com impacto
positivo com líderes inspiradores poder
empreender com autonomia com significado
com já ficou bacana com horários
flexíveis com diálogo aberto
é uma lista imensa de novos ideais que
se construíram sobre o trabalho e que
têm uma série de virtudes que ele vai
falar sobre elas
o que é importante fazer um paralelo por
exemplo eu me formei em 1999 na fgv e de
fato quando me formei pra mim os meus
amigos
a única coisa que a gente discute há
mais ou menos era quem é trabalhar com
bens de consumo que é uma consultoria
para o banco
nossos amigos advogados em um escritório
a b ou c variava muito por disso daí o
papa a gente jogava nas empresas e
começava então uma trajetória e
invariavelmente hoje praticamente
qualquer debate que vai sobre trabalho
sobre o choque de gerações é esse tipo
de cenário que a gente tem que discutir
e a gente vê que o cenário brilhante em
termos de nos provocar e provocar as
organizações a evoluírem para lugares
mais virtuosos fato para movimentos mais
contemporâneos e isso está perfeito para
o ponto que eu queria trazer é quando
esse discurso carlo gado a idealização
que eu comentei no começo quando ele
chega pra jovens nos seus 20 e poucos
anos que por exemplo nunca trabalharam
já se cobram a idéia de que eles têm que
saber o que eles amam que ele tem que
encontrar o propósito que eles têm que
trabalhar num lugar tão fantástico
quanto essa lista é praticamente uma
lista do papai noel
e que de fato até hoje pelo menos a
gente não encontrou lugares que
entreguem esse tipo de perspectiva
nem mesmo as empresas que a gente
imagina que entregam que ajudam para
impulsionar o mercado que tem esse
paradigma quanto e quando a gente vai
fundo na realidade dessas empresas
também uma dialética muito mais complexa
do que às vezes a gente faz parecer
pelos discursos pelas palestras
inspiradoras por livros fantásticos e o
que acontece eu tentei retratar aqui de
uma forma bem simples
quando esse discurso que tem todas as
virtudes que eu já comentei caio no
lugar de idealização de um jovem por
exemplo o jovem pretende dar o contexto
ea gente contou um pouco sobre isso que
vem de um sistema de educação do século
extremamente passivo extremamente
teórico que acha um monte de coisas mas
de fato não experimentou praticamente
nada
e esse ideal ele entra como se fosse
praticamente um muro entre essas pessoas
entre esse jovem e o fazer
gero que a gente chamou da crise dos 20
anos quando isso vem pro ideal tão
grande quanto se construiu sobre o
trabalho a gente ver jovens fantásticos
o movimento de angústia de paralisia
muito grandes o excesso de
possibilidades o excesso de ideais mas
muitos desses jovens simplesmente não se
engajar em nada e ficarem paralisados
ai começar a tomar de fato depressivos
aumentaram demais sessões de coaching de
terapias de psicologia e psicanálise
obviamente nada contra essas esses
trabalhos são fantásticos mas que vem de
fato dá conta de uma nova dor que esse
jovem tem que enfrentar pelo excesso de
mais um ideal a que a gente vê como
contrapartida disso e muitos desses
jovens que a gente trabalha e por acaso
ou por de contrato e alguns aqui nos
ensinou de certa forma como antídoto
dessa paralisia e dessa angústia
antes de falar do antídoto queria
comentar dois paradigmas que a gente
venha dos sintomas claros e se eu
comentei da paralisia ou seja pessoas
que de fato não conseguem se mobilizar
para realizar nada
o pessoas que se que de fato entrou
empresas vão aprender mas logo se depara
com uma realidade que está longe do
ideal que eles imaginavam que seria o
trabalho e então se desengajem muito
rápido ou desistem ou passa a trabalhar
mas já não com a mesma dedicação não com
o mesmo tesão que eles tínhamos primeiro
nas primeiras duas semanas
e aí o que faz de fato de perceber que
essa falta de persistência de entrega
obviamente mais uma boa parte dessa
moçada perder o ciclo fundamental de
ganhar musculatura ganhar maturidade
nesse começo de carreira
o antídoto então como eu tava comentando
que a gente que eu percebo hoje quando a
gente olha para o outro lado da moeda
mas quer de fato uma minoria é uma
relação diferente é quando a idealização
se transforma mais em ideais
o que a gente percebe uma característica
a única que na minha opinião se repete
entre esses jovens se repete também
quando a gente for o preço da biografia
dos grandes empreendedores grandes ligas
grandes empresários tanto no brasil
quanto no mundo e que está nas duas
primeiras palavras que eu falei
toda essa turma histórias mais
diferentes e que isso nas duas escolas
quem não estudou que fala uma série de
idiomas que não fiquei mal falam
português
quem criou negócios digitais em é quem
criou grandes a centros industriais
mas tem uma coisa que permeia 100% dessa
turma que essa conexão direta com o
fazer
é uma relação de muita ação de muito
movimento sustentado para uma segunda
palavra que achava que a persistência
exigente não se deparou com nenhuma
história até hoje que não tenha sido
construído a partir dessas dois pilares
quer fazer e ao persistir pode parecer
muito óbvio dessa forma é mais
exatamente na sobriedade essa
simplicidade que cria a pontuar aqui que
eu acho que um recado importante a ser
dado e o bacana é que essa turma não
abre mão de deixar a mente dos seus
ideais só que eles conseguem colocar
exatamente no lugar de inspiração que os
colocam em movimento e não no lugar da
idealização que mostrar agora pouco isso
o movimento já era virtuosidade gera
transformação e gera impacto dentro
dessa dessa perspectiva
eu queria trazer outros dois pontos que
eu acho que são muito importantes a
gente falou da experimentação do fazer
da persistência e aqui esse protagonismo
na transformação é o fenômeno que a
gente observa que esse discurso
emergente esse novo discurso sobre o
trabalho
obviamente ele se construiu uma
velocidade muito mais rápida do que de
fato as organizações puderam se
mobilizar e se transformar a realidade
aqui hoje 98 99 por cento de qualquer
posição de trabalho que a gente vá ainda
está muito mais voltado em códigos
antigo pelo novo
a gente gostaria que eles já tivessem
alguma forma dentro desses ideais mas
não estão
e qualquer um de nós que está no mercado
de trabalho hoje que está entrando no
mercado de trabalho
somos na verdade convidados a fazer essa
transformação a criar essas pontes não
existe nenhum prato pronto e o que a
gente vê que de certa forma exatamente
pela idealização é muita gente que
espera esse prato pronto para se
encontrar um mercado preparado já dentro
dessas condições nós mesmos na next
demorou para se dar conta disso
como a gente trabalha muito nos ideais
demorou um certo tempo de perceber que
na verdade o mercado ainda está muito
espaço atrás que nós temos que ser
protagonistas dessa transformação e isso
é mais um convite super importante para
todo mundo que está entrando no mercado
de trabalho entender a gente vai
construir essa perspectiva é a beleza
sim sonhar com um castelo em cima das
montanhas mas lembrar principalmente pra
ter um castelo
a gente tem que vai colocar um tijolo
segundo de jogo o terceiro do jogo o
quarto de jogo
não adianta só pensar em só imaginar e
sonhar com esse castelo ea cola que a
gente tem vivido dessa história toda
essa jornada e que a gente vê que é
talvez onde está o maior gap do nosso
sistema de educação é o autoconhecimento
é exatamente na dialética entre o fazer
se conhecer olhar pra dentro que a gente
vê as principais estradas da vida sendo
construídas
de forma mais virtuosa possível porque
exatamente olhando pra dentro que a
gente descobre os ideais e que eles
conseguem se desconectar das
idealizações essa operação é
absolutamente crucial onde nosso sistema
não nos dá praticamente nenhum apoio
nenhuma referência é sem dúvida um
enorme gap é um grupo que nos permite
perceber que na cadeia de idealizações
tudo vai se tratar de uma grande
dialética
vou fazer o que eu amo na minha vida eu
por um bom tempo tem que fazer coisas
que eu não amo talvez a maior parte do
tempo a fazer coisas que eu não amo para
poder fazer o que eu amo encontrar o
nosso propósito nunca pergunta pelo
menos eu quase nunca escuta pergunta
qual o preço está disposto a pagar pra
ir na direcção tem um propósito tipo de
renúncia está disposto a fazer agora no
curto prazo para acolher num longo
equilíbrio de vida é uma popularidade
que vai ter que administrar a vida
inteira não tem uma fórmula mágica que
nos permita chegar no estado perfeito de
equilíbrio é o que vai administrar uma
vida inteira
e esse mergulho pra dentro nos ajuda a
entender a conectar melhor exatamente
com essa perspectiva da dialética e quer
onde o único lugar que consegue ver de
fato uma verdade o que a gente vive no
que a gente experimenta na prática e eu
queria aqui também para complementar um
pouco do dessa conversa aproveitar que
três minutos que ainda tenho pra também
saiu um pouco do do pensamento e dá um
exemplo prático por exemplo de um
programa que a gente tem desenvolvido e
que ele é bastante inspirador para
mostrar como é possível a gente operar e
transformar a realidade que está aí dada
não necessariamente o bom o propósito a
beleza está sempre no que a gente não
tem esse é um programa que a gente criou
o chamado mipim mastro então de programa
praticamente observando três dores
os desafios das empresas que estão
grandes empresas grandes centros
econômicos
as dores e as angústias e os desejos dos
jovens e o gap protal que têm o sistema
de educação e trabalho
então a idéia era ver e pensar pô como
seria fantástico sem tirar essa moçada
da
dentro da sala de aula dessa coisa
passiva e permite se eles experimentarem
visões por exemplo complementares do
mercado de trabalho em razão de uma
empresa de bens de consumo de uma
consultoria estratégica e de um banco de
investimento
a gente pegou convidamos três empresas
que no caso foi a ambev a marquise eo
credit suiss empresas líderes em seus
setores com a com a pegada de alta
performance e eles toparam com a gente
cria uma plataforma onde os jovens por
exemplo hoje podem experimentar essas
três culturas no mesmo programa entender
o que de fato diferencia as culturas que
de fato diferencia estilos diferentes de
liderança e terminar a faculdade com
muito mais propriedade pra começar a
desconfiar do que de fato eles querem do
que de fato ele se conecta do que de
fato faz sentido pra eles mas na prática
vai fazendo experimentando e sendo
suportado ao longo do programa por
alguns modos de autoconhecimento
inteligência emocional inteligência
social que também ajudou a catalisar
essa passagem da academia no mercado de
trabalho
é um projeto que os empresas talvez a
que não são necessariamente com os
códigos da nova economia mas que mostram
também a forma por exemplo tem de pensar
essa passagem de uma de um formato muito
mais colaborativo do que talvez jamais
tinha imaginado
é um programa que tem sido bastante
impactado e tente ouvir a voz dos jovens
não só de que 10 desse programa de
qualquer um que está aqui vai botar a
mão na massa
praticamente um dois três meses fazendo
valer muitas vezes muito mais do que 12
anos na faculdade recebi a informação de
uma forma passiva e desconectada de fato
da realidade
então esse é só um exemplo para mostrar
e nos desafiar a provocar a construção
do futuro do trabalho não imaginar que
está dado e que todos nós aqui sem
dúvida independente da área de atuação
de cada um cabe a nós levar movimentar o
mundo para lugares
o trabalho para lugares que de fato a
gente acredite e se conecte mais
exatamente através dessa dialética aqui
tem visto a coisa funcionar ela fazendo
é olhando pra dentro construindo
entendendo que a gente pode e deve sim
operar a partir do que a gente tem não
só a partir de ideais a partir a de
construções que vem de fora é olhar pra
dentro entender os nossos ideais e
colocar o primeiro tijolo o segundo de
jogo o terceiro de jogo e assim por
diante
como muitos messi já nos falaram muito
tempo o sofrimento nosso sofrimento vem
muito do fato de a gente não aceitar as
coisas como elas são
obrigado gente